hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trainsenses.com so in this video guys as
usual we're gonna go through amc gme
press action i'm also gonna show you uh
some very interesting things on the
global market guys we have a very strong
move up that is happening right now i
also gonna show you some um interesting
signals that i'm having on moderna and
that's not only some technical signals i
think that uh there is a very nice
opportunity on the stock for fundamental
reasons as well and i'm going to show
you that and of course at the end i will
quickly show you what is happening on
the community market especially on the
oil market so let's get into it oh right
guys so first thing amc bam so we are
having a nice day all right so
let me quickly sum up the situation for
those who have not watched the video i
posted yesterday we were here uh we are
basically trying to um
you know find some reversal signals on
amc
because um it looks very much like we
did a first move up that developed
nicely in five waves with a very uh
strong volume coming in the third wave
and an even stronger volume in the fifth
wave usually third waves are the waves
with the strongest volume uh but
sometimes you have a fifth wave
extension this is what happened with amc
whenever you have fifth wave extension
uh you usually go to the 1.618
fib extension
ratio which uh
i think was pretty accurate here i think
i gave you that level guys bam bam bam
as you can see i measure one plus three
i applied to the bottom of the force and
look at that guys bam bam bam 1.618
almost perfectly all right so
uh this is only showing me that
this first wave has followed very well
elliot and fibs
rules so
um
i can assume from that that second third
fourth and fifth wave will also follow
nicely this
rose so here
this is what i'm trying to use to find
where the second wave might bottom and
as you guys know i was um
thinking that we won't go below 21 we
did so right now i'm not exactly sure
we're still in this in the second wave
i'm not sure third wave will come
but it can still come we've seen many
times what we can call some access here
so access is something that is unusual
uh when it comes to technicals so
usually some access happens
above the resistance or below a support
whenever you have some excess on low
volume then usually it's an excess here
as you can see the volume is very low so
i mean i want to believe that we are in
the second wave and that third wave will
come
but the truth is that
right now it's
you know it's looking like best to back
control and that
booze we need to really flex the muscle
we need to see very very strong volume
at the beginning of the third wave for a
massive third wave to happen so let's
see if we can have that so we were
looking yesterday for some reversal
signs and we were having some guys look
at the only time frame we were uh
discussing this bullish divergence that
was here
uh happening so as you can see macd
going higher price action going lower
rsi going higher than here it got a
little bit broken but we still have uh
rsi that is making higher lows
and the price action making lower low so
this is a bullish divergence uh which is
an information that whenever you get it
the probability of a reversal is
increasing but you always always need to
combine this information with a breakout
and i was telling you guys yesterday
that
in this situation you need to find the
trend line that is showing you that uh
that is the more likely to be the
resistance line where bears are gathered
and uh to me it was pretty clear that
this blue trend land is the one what
that we need to pay attention to because
i'm having one two three
all right three four five six seven
eight nine
ten reactions all right ten reactions on
my trend line on my trend line and here
you can see that
we had this consideration we almost
broke out on the upside yesterday but we
got rejected and i was telling you guys
that if we see the press action going
above that level which is a breakout
with a volume increase after this
bullish divergence
it would very much look like the second
wave is complete so
what do we have guys today what do we
have look at that
we have a breakout how do you know it's
a breakout because first it's impulsive
you have big green candles it's not a
small candle it just went through the
level
uh but what is missing here guys what is
missing here tell me what is missing bam
bam bam this is missing guys we don't
have the volume increase we we we have
i mean a small volume increase it's
clearly the biggest volume of the day um
the close has not happened yet
but
i mean compared to the other days it's
not an amazing volume so the signal is
good i'm happy to see that
but i didn't post anything in my discord
because i mean i don't have the volume
so it can very well fake out but we
still are in a situation
that is looking very well because we
have a bullish divergence and we have a
breakout with that volume so maybe it's
a fake out but it's still a good uh
situation to me so uh let's see if we're
able first to close because the close is
right now in
five hours guys
so it's the middle of the day for you
uh and we are
right now trading at 18.1 so let's see
if we're able to uh close above so let
me give you the exact level the exact
level is 18 let's call it 18
17.8 all right if you're able to close
above 18 it will be to me a clear
victory
we don't want to go much higher and then
drop as well so here i mean if we just
stabilize around 18.1 18.2 it would be
perfect it would be a nice three four
percent move up
um
which once again i would like to see
some strong volume happening at the
close i'm gonna money to that of course
guys
um and if we do have that then the daily
volume would be big so even if during
the breakout we don't have such a big
volume if we have the confirmation at
the close because you guys know
that most big money players they trade
close to close or happen to open all
right they don't trade during the day so
the big money is arriving at the open
and at the close mostly at the close all
right the close is the most important
is the most important candle i'm
checking quickly here you can see that
amc usually the open
the opening candles are slightly bigger
in volume
but let's see
open close let's say it's roughly the
same for amc it's not the case for
futures or other uh instruments
but
here if we have a big volume trading on
the at the close maybe the daily volume
would be increasing because once again
we are monitoring here a breakout on the
hourly timeframe but the truth guys is
look at look at that daily volume i mean
it's just
it's insanely low yesterday we had 23
million shares exchanged
guys
okay i can't find
i can't find any lower volume traded in
the past month i mean maybe it has been
the lowest volume trading ever
i mean since we started to move like
crazy on amc maybe we had some i don't
want to look for all i don't want to be
looking for all of them but
um
we have a very very low volume and i
told you guys whenever you have a
consolidation on low volume it doesn't
mean that the reversal will happen it
means that we are in a situation where
it's easy to make a reversal i mean
easier because low volume so you just
arrive with high volume and you know you
can you can just um
go through every orders that is uh
acting as resistance so here it's very
easy to to to make it move but for now
the big money players are not coming in
but we have some good signs on the rest
of the market so let me just conclude
here we have bullish divergence on there
will be breakout on the hourly with that
volume uh we have a consolidation that
has started for the past uh week on amc
we came back to some levels that are
considered to me as
uh buying levels because um
these are the levels where everything
has started uh
one month ago it was at 16 so we had 18
all right we're not at 16 yet but
um
i mean the 1618 area is a is an area
where uh buyers are happy to increase
their position so
um all of that is telling me
that
we are looking good for finally
finally a strong move up to come now
what
where is it gonna where where is it
going to go
i don't know once again the bullish
momentum has been broken guys below 21
but maybe booze are gonna be very strong
so we need to monitor the first impulse
volume that's gonna happen basically at
some point i don't know if it's gonna be
this week or next week or even later but
at some point we're gonna have a massive
move up all right just like we have here
and then we need to monitor if the
volume is increasing as well as it did
here and if yes then it means that we
are back that big money players are back
in the game and once again we need those
guys to go to the 3d area and then 32
guys it's a level that is going lower
right now it's around 31 i would say
here
is the level to go above for the squeeze
to really start all right so we're gonna
monitor that guys i don't know where
when it's gonna happen but i strongly
believe it will happen uh
soon sooner or later so let's find out
that's it for amc guys let's have a look
at gamestop so what is happening on
gamestop let me go on a daily timeframe
we're having it we're having a nice move
up
uh bam bam bam i need to go on a regular
scale all right so i was making my
scenarios
yeah so we were discussing yesterday
this you know double fake out and it
it did happen
all right we had a double fake out okay
let me show you that guys
so
this is just showing that um there are a
lot of traps in this market as you can
see we had here a nice resistance that
has been broken uh without volume
then rejected and then here same thing
we are breaking out below the 142 point
142 level with that volume and then
boost uh take back control so this is a
classic
i would say trading that
some traders are specialized in i do it
sometimes i'm not a specialist of stop
hunting but basically you enter you
don't buy breakouts
you sell them whenever they happen on
low volume and once again for those who
interested guys i'm explaining all of
that in my course and i have a big
announcement to make guys as many of you
were asking me i know this course is
expensive but once again i spent so much
time writing it and i'm very sure
against that the content that you can
find in this course you can't find it
anywhere else because it's some
original content that i did myself that
is based on my experience and my
techniques on everything that i've read
and everything that some experienced
shadows
uh taught me when i was working as a pro
trader for the past seven years so right
now guys this course is available you
can have only the pdf so it's like 66
pages of
um explanation a theory of examples so
it's basically the same thing as the
videos but i i'm not here to explain to
you so if you prefer to read you can
have it and the price is much cheaper
it's 150 us dollars and you have a gold
uh membership one month gold membership
that is at 50 us dollars included in
that guest so basically you have the
full course and i also included um
some videos one hour of video uh so that
at least you see how the videos are
looking uh and guys i think that uh if
you want to learn there is nothing
better that you can do for yourself than
getting this course so click on the link
in description of this video i've just
added it today yes and you can access
this course you have the full course for
only 150 and once again you can come to
discord for free during one month
all right so in this course i'm
explaining exactly what is this stop
hunting um
what are those stump hunting strategies
i'm giving example to show how it's
working and here we have two nice
examples uh so right now what's gonna
happen i don't know we are back into
this range 150 to 140 252. i don't see
any um bullish signal happening on gm
for now because once again you guys know
that i like to trade breakouts and bam
we are just
okay it's pretty interesting look at
that we are consolidating so you can
wonder why are we consolidating here
and i can tell you is that uh it's
because we have this trend line all
right as you can see one direction here
i'm just connecting in the highs all
right using the regular scale one two
three and once again that's why i told
you guys i prefer to use the regular
scale on gme once again here it's giving
me very good reactions very good trend
line i can see that
this trend line is used by more trader
than only me
and once again i just spotted something
bam bam bam you also can put this one so
we have a double kind of trend line here
you have one two three four reactions
and here one two three so i'm not sure
actually if it's coming from this one or
this one or probably both but we have
sellers that are here gathered and bulls
are trying to go through but for now we
have a ceiling that we can't go above so
um let's move into that once again guys
if we are able today to close above this
blue and green trend lines so let's say
we close around 149.
uh it would be a breakout signal on gme
not perfect because here i don't have a
very nice consolidation as you can see
we're coming from the lows uh amc is a
little bit the same issue guys so once
again for breaker to be really good
quality you need to have a consideration
close to the resistance and once again
if you want to really understand
everything yes because i can't give you
here all the information i did this
course that is for you eight hours of
video where i explain everything for
beginners so
here it's still interesting for you to
know that whenever the consideration is
far from the resistance area
then even if we have a breakout it's a
bit less
good quality okay less reliable so here
we are testing this level so it's always
good to you know see bulls really um
you know gathered just below the
resistance area so let's see what's
gonna happen here but it's looking
pretty good to me as well
i would just like to have this close
uh ideally with increasing volume
above 149
and amc just to close you know close to
the
high of the day would be perfect for
tomorrow
uh all right guys now triple q guys once
again this is where i make my money but
today let's be honest i make money
pretty much everywhere i know i lose
money on um on commodities i'm going to
show you that but i make a good day
yesterday was a negative day today is a
good day
uh and i make most of my money here guys
i told you i gave you this trade uh in
discord i gave you this trade as well
here if you are following me i was a
buyer three three seven point five
thirty eight but i i got done a little
bit below stop plus three three three
five
and right now guys as you can see we
having finally this uh strong buddhist
reaction all right so
uh pam pam pam you can do some trend
lines as well here you see where it a
little bit like amc all right market
going lower but we were having i didn't
show you that guys here but you know it
was as well some of the reasons um that
made me feel bullish here
the bears were just losing steam as you
can see they're losing steam because
they're going lower they're taking
ground when the bearish move the market
is making lower lows but the momentum
indicators max the rsi are making higher
lows which is showing that uh bears are
out of steam so whenever we have that
same thing guys we're waiting for a
breakout i personally bought the dip
here because i had a support as well uh
in this area
so i used the daily time frame analysis
to enter my trade but on the hourly
timeframe you can make some nice trades
too
uh i'm not sure you would have bought
this level but what you could have done
is once again uh but we don't have the
volume oh right you can see here we have
a breakout
that happened together with amc and same
thing guys not big volume so let's see
maybe we're just going to get rejected
as you saw on gme whenever we broke out
below above or below
resistance or support we then got
rejected
uh and faked out so here i don't know
what's gonna happen i'm personally
bullish
and i'm targeting 350. what i'm gonna do
i can tell you quickly here if we go to
350 i'm gonna take full profit so i'm
gonna be flat
and then
i don't want to take any more trade here
because here it's a 50 50 probability we
can go higher or lower i don't want to
play that i mean it's pretty useless
but i will wait and if we come here then
i will take again a short position
if we break out here then i will take a
bullish position on the retest if i see
volume happening here
and if you get rejected
i don't think i'm gonna buy here if we
get rejected here
i will see but i will probably wait to
see what's gonna happen here if we break
out on the downside then i'm gonna play
the retest okay so
basically
there is always a trade to do on triple
q and that's very good because once
again guys for those who are with me in
this code you know that all the trades
we've done on triple q were successful
trades we didn't lose money i did like i
don't know maybe 10 trades maybe one or
two were losers but i didn't
take the loss on the losers i let it go
and in the end all of the trades that i
made on triple q s triple q
uh
spy you know the global market were
positive which is good guys because uh
the trades that i made on the meme
stocks didn't
go so well so this this is the reason
why it's always good to um
to have a mixed
investment in your portfolio don't
always invest in the same assets uh
asset class
so here uh to conclude on triple two
it's looking good i think we're going to
go to 350 and then let's see so we are
in the situation we wanted to be in gas
you remember i was talking yesterday
about the negative beta that was
starting to take place that i wanted to
see but i told you guys that the
negative beta is useless if
we are in a
bear market or at least very strange and
right now guys maybe
i said maybe
we're gonna have here a strong move up
that could happen all right if this is
happening guys
amc will very very likely
squeeze
but the probability of this third wave
just by itself i'm not talking about the
squeeze here is not that big guys i give
it a 25 chance
this is what i said uh i'm not sure if i
said it in the discord or to a friend i
give a 25 25 chance we go higher i give
a 50 chance we stay sideways and i give
um a 25 chance that we move lower so
you're gonna tell me yeah
i mean your probabilities are very
uh i would say um
conservative maybe but this is really
what i believe and i'm personally gonna
buy here sell here and play this ranging
move i think we're gonna move sideways
uh but once again i'm open to pretty
much
you know every scenario it it's gonna
depend on what's when what's gonna
happen on um
in in the world right so let's check
when it's power talking guys
fed daily speech
okay in two days
probably is talking in two days okay
guys so we're gonna see this can be a
market mover so we're gonna see what is
what he's saying about inflation
uh i think that russia it's not that
thing i know that russia has started its
um i would say last battle of the
dumbass you know i told you guys
yesterday that i don't believe this war
can end quickly and i told you that both
parties will fight
strong once again i'm not war experts i
have no clue what's gonna happen
um but
i think that
what can be said for sure is that
it's gonna take some time because none
of the uh camp wants to um
to give ground and right now they seem
pretty even right we were thinking that
russia will just
uh destroy ukraine uh army and actually
ukraine destroyed the
the boat you know a massive uh boat from
the army so um they're pretty much even
right now and i think that um
that bad things are about to happen and
that um
i'm not sure how the markets will react
to that so this is the reason why i am
personally
um
not very bullish not bearish either
because the fundamentals are still
strong in the world you know we have a
full employment in the united states
we still have some good growth um in in
most of the countries of the world so i
mean
it can still go higher so let's find out
my
take is that we're gonna move sideways
for the pa for the coming three months
so let's see
uh bam bam bam
that's done guys and now i have some
cool
trade idea to show you of course i gave
it to my discord this morning guys it's
modern alright so all of you know
moderna
alright so a lot of information here and
guys i'm going to show you some cool
things some very cool things we don't
need rsi okay so look at that
let's go on a weekly time frame
okay
i go on a weekly timeframe guys because
uh
okay i cannot make it bigger because
it's important we have the magnet here
okay bam great
okay
uh oh right yes so look at that
this is madonna since 2019 so it's um
it's a rocket right it's going higher
from 13 to 500 so it did a massive move
up developing in five waves as
uh most of the moves up uh in this
market
and
then we broke out below this trend line
by the way i took a bearish position
here and i made some money around three
three
three hundred thirty um
we had this breakout as you can see
okay and since then we are developing
lower all right so whenever we are in
this situation
you guys know that
we are in a corrective move we are
looking for breakout for reversal
breakout if you want to be early for
continuation breakout if you want to be
safe but enter the higher level once
again all of that is explained in the
course and here
uh so we're having this move down so
whenever we move down we are looking for
a bracket and once again this is
something i wanted to show you guys here
uh whenever you see the mac deforming a
megaphone pattern and i'm explaining
that once again very well in the course
it means that you're on a strong and
healthy trend strong because you don't
have any bearish divergence coming
from in the move up
and uh healthy because you have a hidden
bullish divergence market making higher
highs between here and here right we are
still going to move up between this and
this market making higher highs
the momentum making lower
lows sorry higher lows and the momentum
making
lower lows which is showing that we are
reloading okay the momentum is the
energy guys is the speed energy see the
way you want but whenever the momentum
is going lower than before it means that
you are reloading energy but the market
is making higher lows which means we are
in a move up so inside the move up we
have reloaded all right so this is
a healthy trend right so a macd
microphone pattern is
the sign that you are in a strong and
healthy trend so we like this kind of
setups so whenever we're in this kind of
setup we are then looking for
um breakouts once again reversal or
continuation
and here i have a nice reversal breakout
that i shared on the forum for those who
took the course you saw this uh trade
uh last month guys uh bam bam bam it was
here
and as you can see i have a wedge
pattern here okay descending wedge uh
i'm having the usual bullish divergences
that are associated in this wedge as you
can see might be going higher rsi going
higher
market going lower and then here bam
breakout okay do we have the increase in
volume we do have it again
so on the weekly time frame the breakout
is here but on the daily timeframe the
breakout is here up up up
okay and as you can see here we had the
volume increase so um this breakout is
to me good quality
it's a wedge so like i explained very
well guys in the course
i closed it but um
if you go on my website this is uh one
of the
examples that i'm showing is that
whenever you buy a wedge breakout and
you guys probably are trading a lot of
wedges if you like to buy the dip if you
like to buy something that is
uh low in price
uh you often have a wedge at the end of
those uh moves and actually you often
have many wedges once again i'm
explaining that in the course but
usually don't buy the first wedge wait
for a second one because the wedge is
usually hiding another wedge okay
whatever here
we have this wedge pattern that gave us
a breakout and we don't buy
right away in the course i'm explaining
as well when it's time to enter if you
should wait for a pullback re-test or if
you should buy right away for wedge
pattern most of the times we wait for a
pullback and we buy around the 61.8
percent retracement all right this is
the exact method that you guys should
apply
and this is a good example because
madonna is coming right now at this
level we have here a bullish reaction so
this morning i posted an alert guys
in my discord uh because and i said
usually the trade i would here propose
is to buy uh at the 61.8 and stop loss
uh you know somewhere here depending on
where their consolidation or either 130
something something like that but for
modern guys i don't want to use a stop
loss all right um and this is the reason
why here uh it's better to
make a smaller size and to keep some uh
shares to buy lower to average down
dollar average down
i'm sure you have heard of this strategy
which is just consisting of
increasing your position if uh the
market is dropping and is giving you the
opportunity to average down your entry
price
so your entry level
so here
the reason why i don't want to use the
usual techniques which is using a stop
loss is because guys
i mean moderna was training at 500. now
it's running at 150 so we we can think
all right yeah but maybe it was
overvalued but guys look at that
whenever i go to bloomberg right so
bloomberg is
uh
something that i'm using that i was
using when i was working that is giving
you a lot of information about the
market and you can have for example you
can find that everywhere but the price
earning ratio when i go on moderna and i
check the price earning ratio i guess i
have five 5.5 all right so the price
earning ratio is something that allows
you to compare uh it's basically the
price
of um
it's the price of the company divided by
the earnings so the higher it is the
more overvalued the company
may might be right then you would
actually need to compute the expected
earnings but it's not changing much
uh here we go from is that so you have
the estimated price earning ratio and
the pe estimate with p and p depending
on the expectations of the earnings but
here
we can see that it's not moving much and
five is very very low let me show you
and it means that the company is very
very much undervalued compared to its
earnings i think that modern earnings uh
in as we can check that in uh last year
were around 15 billion so
basically
if
modernized trading at 100
this is
what it's worth i mean this is the value
if monday is trading at 100 it means
that the company's value is equal to the
earnings they made in one year so here
bam
okay i'm not going to compute everything
but basically modena cannot go below 100
because they're making money right there
are so many companies today that don't
make money and that you know there is a
discussion is it of a value is it on the
value i don't know but whenever company
is making money making profits so you're
gonna tell me yeah but it was because of
the kovid
um true but guys i mean i have some
friends that are very very into madonna
and
they explain to me once again you can
check by yourself that madonna is on
many many different uh vaccines they're
working on the aids vaccine as well
and the technology they created is the
future all right the a r and a
technology that is used for the pfizer
vaccine
um is the future and they're gonna use
that for everything all right so
we were always going to need vaccine
maybe it's going to be photocopy maybe
another um sickness but a virus but what
i mean is that
the phantom of those are strong
the business model is strong uh and the
technicals are giving me a breakout so
i think that this is a very nice buying
opportunity but if it goes lower because
it's possible guys
uh then it's just better to increase the
position and here the targets guys are
very high if
this is what i think which could be a
first wave
of a major new move up
uh
then as you can see guys
we would go towards the you know one
thousand two thousand i have even some
friends that some friends that are
convinced that modena will go to three
thousand in two or twenty five so maybe
two twenty five two twenty five is here
guys
okay maybe i don't know
maybe but 150 seems very very low for
company that is making so much money
that's all i can say i mean those are
figures there is no speculation here and
technicals are giving me some breakouts
now what i also said to my discord this
morning
is that if you want to play it safe you
don't buy reversal breakouts which are
more risky because once again you're
going to move down and you try to
predict the reversal all right so it's
not easy because you are just going
against the trend one basic rule in
training is go with the trend the trend
is your friend that's true
all right that's true if you want to
make money
go with the flow trade
trade with the trend and
i sometimes like to buy reversal
breakouts when i have whenever i have a
good situation i think that this is a
good situation but it's a risky trade
the less risky trade is to wait for
continuation breakout so you wait for
the price action to come here to make a
nice consolidation just below this
yellow trend line that is here and then
you buy this breakout that could happen
maybe in june
around the 200
200 level 210 220. so
i hope we're gonna be there because that
personally gonna buy before that but if
you guys didn't buy and you see the
signal uh once again i think it's gonna
be a very nice buying opportunity and to
conclude on today's video guys we have
oil that i'm following with you for
quite some time i think this is a big
market mover today uh today oil is um
getting
dumped
down 4.4.8
so i'm losing money here but uh it's a
nice opportunity to reload
uh i actually reloaded here uh but just
a small call option
uh because to me we are still looking
good i mean i told you yesterday that we
have this breakout here above this
triangle without volume and that
whenever you don't have volume usually
bears attack it so to me this is just an
attack from bears i think it's going to
hold
if we go below 100
it would start not to be looking good
just like amc going below 21 all right
it's the same situation we have the 61.8
fib ratio at 99.6
so
i'm happy to buy in this area but if we
go below 98 i would start to sell what i
bought to take my loss because you never
know this is just a trading signal
everything can happen
um and of course the war is gonna have a
big impact on that so let's see uh what
is that what is gonna happen there we
have uh french election presidential
elections as well happening this weekend
that can have an impact on the old
market because of the embargo that uh
the embargo that um
europe and u.s want to do with russian
oil so let's see if they are able to do
it it's gonna depend once again on who
is um
president in france uh macron is for it
le pen is against that embargo
so let's find out guys but for now to me
this is a buying opportunity and
and yes that's pretty much it guys thank
you very much for watching i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget and yes also sorry guys i
didn't find how to fix my mic i have
only the sun from the left side so maybe
some of you can help me
basically
you need to go to the microphone
properties and to change from two
channel to one challenge to one channel
for the amplificator that you use and i
don't have that option i checked one
hour today so if some of you know how to
fix the problem so i'm using the
scarlett the focus right
focusrite scarlett um speaker
microphone so just
tell me in the comments guys if you have
any clue how to solve this issue because
otherwise i'm sorry it's gonna uh it's
gonna keep being like that for now so
now that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys